there's a secret that you don't know
about decisions it's called you wouldn't
have known the alternative and so it
doesn't [__] matter
when you make a decision you've made a
decision and you actually don't know how
the other way would have worked out you
think you would have known well if I
went to Amazon instead of this [__]
company 20 years ago I would have made
all this money you might have got fun
from Amazon you might have been going to
work one day at Amazon and gone to a car
accident that changed her health you
don't know
with all of you nobody [__] knows you
can't fear decisions it's the way we
live as humans you're making decisions
every day you decided to come here we
are crippled by the unknown when we
can't control it you have to let go what
you're really saying is I'm scared the
[__] up and then have people judge me
for it being a human being is making
decisions and living with it that's the
game and there's no other way to do it